a few episodes ago we inadvertently
stumbled upon a new segment called sound
effects theater where
sona and i set up environments and uh
conan you made the sound effects of the
things in that environment but
only using spoken word yeah i decided
that
too much work and trouble goes into
you know for movies and tv shows and
radio shows especially podcasts
trying to recreate the actual sound of a
door opening
uh or a cat walking and so i decided why
don't you just have someone say
door open you know and people will get
the idea it's a genius
well you know what i know you're being
sarcastic yeah but
i think i might be on to something
because we should try to make
podcasts in particular as easy for
everyone to use
and to create that would be more
democratic
let's this is a favor we're doing not
everyone has to go out and buy special
effects or download them on some
computer
do it my way and i think we demonstrated
with our episode
that it really works it's it got a huge
response
what it did but you're doing sound
effects theater as an act of charity
no as a man who's not afraid
to look at something and say
why can't it be different you all look
at what is and go
that is i say couldn't it be something
different
that's what makes me a visionary in my
opinion
oh okay all right well you said it was
what sick you said we did a good job
like it was successful it was
it blew up awful oh but we were terrible
the job was smack it was
a big hit i've had people stop me on the
street and ask for more sound effects
theater
and i've said sorry um
it's a lot of work and i don't have time
for that kind of foolishness and then as
i walk away i go
walk away walk away walk away walk away
kills every time
okay so the last time we did this was on
the seth rogen episode if you want to
check it out but um
i'm just going to throw something out in
an environment sona will
and i will be in that environment we'll
set you up for sound effects are you
guys ready
oh yeah i was born to do this i'm not
i'm terrible at improv i
i think no you're not that should
already really be yeah you really
can't be any worse than the sound
effects you don't have anything to worry
about yeah okay
laugh all you want but i think i'm
honest okay all right
all right let's say this time uh okay
we're
we're on the a battlefield oh all right
sergeant obsession hand me the colt 45
pistol
yeah uh yes the colonel yes
can't you see these birds on my helmet
you're right back talk to them
hand me the coal what who wait a minute
you can't even
wait no no no so stupid no no how about
you
the sun effects if you can't even talk i
can talk
i just i've never been he gave you and
also it's not like
improv is all about making interesting
choices he gave you a direct order i
know
all you have to do is say yes sir
because it's so easy you struggled with
his imaginary
rank how are we supposed to make any
progress
he literally it's just a yes sir here
you go
not like oh okay colonel who i
met in indianapolis
but you don't have to do that okay i'm
sorry um let's try it again
and uh you know simplify okay just keep
it simple yeah okay
sergeant your colt 45.
all right we'll do that colonel oh
now please [ __ ] the slide of the weapon
and chamber around
sure thing did you just call me a [ __ ]
my gun did i'm sorry okay sorry
all right now i would like you to
discharge your weapon at the target yes
colonel
for your [ __ ] i think your gun just
sneezed bless you
is your gun okay i don't know colonel
it's it's acting up
weird so let me i'm smacking it so that
it'll
work better rattle rattle ravel all
right we're gonna move on to something
bigger i would like you to set up
the m60 machine gun yes sir
unfold please [ __ ] it uh yes sir
[ __ ] what did you say to me sergeant
obsession
i'm so sorry look in my eyes that's two
strikes you get one more chance at this
please fire multiple rounds of this
machine gun
oh yes sir rupees fire shooters would be
first who would be cancelled would be
perfect where people should repeat fire
shoots
all right sergeant oh no incoming fire
artillery
[Applause]
[Music]
sergeant sergeant i'm hit can't you hear
the blood geysering out of my veins
i can
[Music]
spill spill i'm not well
sounds not really bad pom pom
you said geysering and it sounds like
it's just dribbling out
yeah it seems weird right let me listen
again
that's more like it yeah pressure poor
oh my god let me get a bandage and wrap
that up for you sir
rip it out you took my heart out
why are you doing this that's the
bandage you idiot oh my god did you hear
that
i'm a talking bandage hey what wilbur
the talking
bandage just happened a new advanced
bandage that can talk
wow it has a small chip we're made by
google all right what should i do now
colonel uh just just stitch me up and
then we gotta do this quick because uh
we need to call in an airstrike on the
radio so could you dial up the uh
the uh home headquarters yes sir road to
return
road to
[Music]
is there anybody there headquarters
headquarters this is delta 9 calling
delta 9 to headquarters
voice voice voice that's them all right
voice otherwise it wouldn't be a voice
voice voice voice period all right we'd
like you to send in some
napalm at my coordinates niner niner
delta niner
well i don't have a lot of confidence
it's a weak sounding bomb
oh no it's headed right for us
we need you okay rocks is one
two three oh shoot oh scissor scissors
what does scissors sound like anyway
sniff a snip or snip a cut
that's right snip a cut okay one two
three i get to die
god you're so lucky i can hear your last
breath coming out of your mouth
exhale spirit go
to the hell
you shoplifted me come on man
mentioned it on previous